kaley cuoco hilarious bachelor fail I'm  Chris Harrison  and this is bachelor live The Bachelor  has a new live after show where fans can  call in and talk to the Stars and turns  out Kaley Cuoco rickly really wanted to  chat with bachelor van on premiere night  yep but no luck  Kaley couldn't get through but now that  Kaylee's is share that video maybe  she'll get to come on the show  bachelor live it does have celeb guests  each week abigail breslin actually  Skyped in it to the premiere  my one question is like why like and I  mean this is the best of senses but why  do you keep calling the girls young  ladies like I said sometimes I say to  mock word things  you